hey everybody and welcome to a
magical wild ride with stevo man did i
fall in love with this guest and if
you're not sure who he is
let me put it to you this way if you've
ever seen a video that had an illusion
some kind of crazy viral magic
it was probably zach king and he's
got to be the coolest dude ever man
really a lot of fun i also want to tell
you that i just got back from my first
stop on the bucket list tour since the
pandemic
and that show is on fire man go to
stevo.com to check out my dates dude
because you don't want to miss it
it's so much fun just like this podcast
so let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen zach king
yeah dude what's up everybody we're in
the back of this uh amazing
rv bus i don't know what you what do you
call this it would be a conversion class
b
motorhome yeah uh rv but it's more than
a sprinter van
uh it's a it's a rolling podcast studio
man it's
it's six inches wider than uh than a
sprinter
runs on gas not diesel but i find myself
in the weeds
you've met scott randolph my co-host and
thank you for doing this man
thanks for having me thanks for having
me i'm taking notes because uh i think
we talked about doing a podcast like
maybe two years ago and we wanted to do
in the back of an airstream
yeah which now seeing you set up roll up
like it's no joke it's a lot of work
so dude plus that's us rolling up with
everything already still set up from the
podcast we recorded yesterday yeah
we've never done that before i mean dude
and we've never done that before because
we didn't want to have the equipment
like banging around while we drove yeah
but uh we rolled the dice on it we
strapped everything down with velcro
straps and without any strat now
i think i think that if we can
rack them up and knock them down a bunch
at a time that's good that's the way to
go
do you guys usually bulk through your
podcast oh yeah i've never done one
without scott i don't think and uh
we would have do you do them in bulk
like in a week
a day we never seek to do uh do it any
certain way we just
the only priority we have isn't getting
like
solid guests because everybody and their
mom
has a podcast i believe there are two
million podcasts out there
yeah it's just like kind of embarrassing
honestly
to ask people will you do my podcast
it's like
i mean it's kind of like youtube and
just social media in general i feel like
it's never been
a better time to be a creator you know
but at the same time
it's never been harder to get exposure
to having an audience and actually do
something that feels
unique and a little bit original to rise
above the noise right
yeah and uh our philosophy in doing that
is just to
try to have like really high standards
for guests
um which you have met well hey thanks
i'm honored
yeah you've met our standards and uh i
think that
most every single person who i mentioned
that we were going to do a podcast with
you was
oh my god i'm so stagnant wait is that
the magic guy from vine
yeah what's he doing these days so uh i
mean i think it's evident that you're
way bigger on tick tock than you ever
were on vine right
it's you know we kind of predicted it
not tick tock but
years ago we would talk about someday
there's gonna be do you remember um
there's this kid named alex from target
that was trending a couple years ago and
it was twitter it's one of these guys
like i think it was just that he was a
good looking dude some girl took a photo
of him
at target and he went viral overnight
and we always predicted that there'd be
this time and i think it's going to get
even crazier
where you're going to get people that
get to 50 million 100 million 250
million subscribers followers whatever
they call it on the platforms
in a matter of you know months or even
less than a year like
right time is increasing exponential and
that's what's interesting to watch like
you see it with i think the latest
example is probably
probably bella porch is a great example
just what looks like
overnight success right and
and increasing the
the stakes of the potential pitfall of
having
so many subscribers and not the views
right that's like the worst
it's like being being famous and broke
yeah and you're your engagement's just
not there
right people aren't really there maybe
an audience in numbers but not really
watching
right and uh it's so tough how
just completely democratic absolutely
scientific
that the the digital landscape is you
know you're just
out in the wind absolutely exposed for
exactly how you're doing in the
popularity contest of life
yeah i i don't i don't view it that way
as much i think i used to when i started
um you know i've been doing youtube for
almost probably 12 13 years
in the beginning it was like what are
the reasons people are following why is
this going viral let's look at like the
hot spots and
and you can still they give you so many
metrics now you could you spend your
whole life in the back end trying to
figure it out but for me
in my team we kind of have a philosophy
of trying to make what we just what our
taste is what we
enjoy i mean imagine it's when you guys
were making
jackass years ago it's like maybe the
networks weren't giving you the data
right like you
made the thing put it out years later
really find out how it did
um and the numbers like i feel like it's
kind of like that approach i enjoy
um throwing it against the wall and
obviously we have 24 hours later
real time now heck you can you can see
how it does
and you can take that back into your
writing room and start the process over
again
but i also think there's things i would
compromise on if i was trying to get
the best engagement or the best views um
you know
certain thumbnails you'd have to make
but i feel like
if if i like i don't fully want to go
that route i
integrity is really important like um
i never will seek to mislead my audience
with some kind of a click bait thing
that doesn't deliver right
in the video for but with that said i
will absolutely
myself out my friends out i'll
sell my soul
to try to get the views with the right
thumbnail and the right title right
but it will always be what it promises
to and i think
for for us and you might be similar
where it starts with that core of this
like if you know the story idea is good
if you know that gag is good or that
yeah thing is going to be funny or hit
right that's where we're what we're
trying to like start with
level one that's like where we want to
focus not
starting on level one being the metrics
i think that's going to
be the step in the wrong direction right
am i okay to ask like it's it's not like
i'm asking you how much
your net worth is but like what's the
term what's like he hasn't asked people
for
blatantly yeah how many millions do you
have no
no no no i've got an advantage what's
the most like views you've ever gotten
on tick tock versus vine
you want to talk about views you should
get a view of my
underwear because i've never been more
in love
with a company's underwear than me
undies man
so stylish not only do they make these
underwear
from totally sustainable materials
the choices are virtually endless man
god do i have a killer deal for you if
you go to meundies.como
you're going to get 15 off your first
order
of these unbelievably comfortable
underwear
plus if you sign up for the membership
oh man you're getting first access
totally killer discounts and
awesome underwear sent to you every
single month i'm telling you
it's all about me undies so again
for 15 off your first order and free
shipping
go to meundies.com
stevo now let's talk about views
so i i don't remember vine i mean uh
vine was
loops right so that was kind of mystery
second
um probably a couple hundred million
loops on a video but now like
i think we hold the record for the
number one tick tock video which is wild
it's me a video of me rolling up looks
like i'm floating on a broomstick
roll up and it reveals like there's a
mirror with a leg glued to it and
that's how he pulled off the illusion
i'm on a like electric skateboard
just floating there holding the broom in
the mirror and i think it has like two
point something billion
wow and i don't know their full loop
metric either but i think it's every
eight hours it counts the new unique
view
um and it like broke the tick tock team
told us it broke their algorithm for the
view count and it started actually going
in reverse
because they didn't ever plan for a
video getting that many views
now they've updated it since and i
believe they've updated the uh
the view count because i i've been
checking
a video i put on tick tock and and it's
updating like what seems real time
yeah like certainly more than every
eight hours yeah what's the most views
you've gotten on tick tock
i don't know i think like 7.6 but i have
a problem with tick tock which is that
it seems to be such a sensitive platform
that they're very quick to take down
videos that i put up
citing violation of community guidelines
despite the fact that the very same
videos
have been perfectly acceptable on every
other social media platform yeah
they're very uh i've seen that they're
cracking down on the policies
what kind of videos obviously i just saw
an email this week they took away you
can't do gambling you can't talk
about damn you can't talk about credit
cards or um
contests or sweepstakes like there's a
huge list of things right okay
um but yeah i imagine your content gets
flagged a lot i think i've had
one that was flagged i don't remember
what it was but uh
it uh got taken down and we actually
reposted it and i think
it it probably the repo slipped through
yes it slipped through fine
um yeah i uh you know like
i kind of take it hard when something
gets taken down
i've had i've had for uh for dangerous
activity
you know that could result in serious
injury uh i've had it taken down
for um illegal activity
and and that was just a video of me
climbing up the crane protesting sea
world
yeah you know like that was taken down
that one should probably be allowed did
they ever allow it
no not at all and then i've had another
one taken down for being sexually
suggestive
when all it was was me bouncing a rubber
ball into a woman's cleavage
yeah i bet they have your name and like
send straight to the same person
like yep it's stevo full disclosure
though uh it wasn't just bouncing the
ball into cleavage what it played into a
promo i said i'm selling
autograph dick pics at stevo.com
yeah they said that it was uh i was
promoting uh
the sale of like pornography which i was
okay well
they busted you rightfully so yeah right
they did they did
but like i said same content was totally
cool on every other platform yeah
um so uh dude i gotta tell you man that
um
i'm impressed i haven't even been in
your compound but
like rolling up here your compound is
epic
your team is like the most accommodating
team of all time
and they were stoked when they knew you
guys were coming cool and the team
meeting they just
some of them flipped out you know i
don't know if they've already taken
photos with you
no but i'm always happy to take photos
with absolutely everybody but yeah
i mean the team i work with i'm i'm so
i've gone back and forth over the years
because i started you know as a
filmmaker solo like i did this all by
myself
i had friends that were filmmakers but
we also had our own track
so when i started a business there was
seasons i would go through where i was
like i don't really know if this is
fulfilling the creator in me like i'm
having to do
be basically a ceo run the business side
of things um
figure out how we're gonna make payroll
this month and
write some of the creative stuff and man
and then manage people like it's a whole
extra job
right i do think over the years i've
seen it
managing people and getting to
collaborate with awesome people in the
world it totally outweighs
all the other you know sometimes baggage
that comes along with it
extra tasks sure i think that
as a function of uh
like meeting all these crazy people who
we
do the podcast probably the biggest
benefit is
in in really sort of getting to
download like their their approach as
much as possible
you know we see how many people have we
see how people operate
we see like uh you know how they run
their business
like what they have to say about and we
really glean a lot of information
you know like we uh did a podcast with
casey neistat yep
like short order within the next two
weeks and putting up vlogs
you know we have we collaborated with
david dobrik and he said
you know his number one revenue stream
is merch and we just started the merch
line
i mean we had the merch line but we
really really
sort of re-like uh rebuilt our approach
to it
yeah that's that's the one part of the
business we haven't figured out we
even came close to i mean we're probably
we're still talking about like do we
shut the thing down because it's
won a lot of work but i also i'm not a
person that naturally is like
hey go buy this shirt you know in right
in the video so maybe if that's not me
it does need to be cancelled um so you
have a merch operation but you're
thinking
we have it and there's like fans who are
dedicated that'll love it and buy it no
matter
what we put out but it's just it's a lot
of work like i i'm more
leaning um like i like to focus our
efforts on the things that are doing
really well and just like lean into a
little more and then slowly open up
other ones that you know are successful
how much
of your content uh do you get branded
integration uh the math is it's probably
like 25
we do a lot of wow original content you
know 75
unbranded the passion projects the short
films all that
and then we'll do integrations um in the
middle of pieces so
i don't i don't love doing the fully
dedicated ones anymore those are a ton
of work
usually the client reviews are pretty
crazy right and you have to at some
point compromise on
of course hopefully not but like you're
stepping that line of like i i feel like
i'm compromising
right so we try to do just little
integrations which will be a 30-second
piece
in the middle much like i think in the
middle of the podcast you guys have
um you know your sponsors for sure it's
like that and uh but i love adding our
twist to it
uh you know it's like when we get the
brief it's actually fun like i think a
lot of people are like oh i have to do
that sponsor this month but right for us
it's like well how do we take this and
really
make it something our fans are gonna
love is there a way we really
we give something back to our fans from
the brand like there's a lot of creative
ways you can
integrate brands and that's a fun
challenge for me i take it so seriously
man
and every time i see a comment on our uh
you know youtube for the podcast or
anywhere yeah where people
uh acknowledge the effort that i put
into the ad reads yeah you know we have
the little trick where we pull off the
screen
we always like build it into the context
of what's being said in the podcast
i do everything you did one with coyote
peterson which actually threw me for a
loop
uh you were like i got a question for
you and then you went right into
you know when people compliment the way
that we approach
our ad breaks on this podcast man it
makes me
hard as a rock i'm just kidding but what
really makes me hard as a rock is blue
chew
tablets why because they have the same
active ingredient as both
viagra and cialis and if you don't know
how good of a time it is to take
bluetooth tablets
i think you might want to pay close
attention right now
because it's so simple and it is so fun
it requires no awkward in person
visit to a doctor no you just go to
bluechew.com
and you consult with one of their
medical professionals online it's super
fast it's super easy
and then you get your bluetooth tablets
in the mail you know what's even better
is that if you use the promo code stevo
bluechu.com you will get an entire
month's
supply completely for free all you have
to pay is
five dollars for shipping oh man is
there nothing to lose and
oh boy do i love blue chew tablets man
i show lux after i chew one up because
they're chewable
and delicious and they cost only a
fraction
of the price of the other ones you know
oh man i show lux my tongue and it's
blue
she gets so excited we jump in bed we
have the greatest time ever
i'm telling you if you're a dude and you
want to get a real major boner
it's time to go to bluechew.com
and use the promo code stevo for an
entire month's supply
of bluetooth tablets and all you have to
pay is five dollars for shipping i'm
telling you
it's the best deal going so do it
and now let's get back to zach i got a
question for you right
and uh i don't remember what the sponsor
was but you started talking and i was
like
i thought you were asking coyote and i
was into it i was listening to the whole
and i was like that was genius like the
way i don't know if that was intentional
it let me
like replace our ad reads at the most
like kind of commercial break yeah and i
was leaning i was leaning in right to
the interview at that point
yeah it's like it's like tv shows you
know they go to commercial like on a
real cliffhanger moment you know
so that you've got everybody's attention
you're not squandering it
and then by trying to like you know
really make it pertinent in the context
of what's being said
like you make it much more palatable
enemy dude
like not not to name any names man but i
see people doing podcasts
and like they're literally holding up
the page
from the sponsor it's like for what's
like needs to be
talking about a lifeless a lifeless read
just like yeah just like where they they
appear to be reading it for the first
time
and it's just like i can't do that man i
care too much about doing
like solid business for people who i
work with
yeah and and delivering like palatable
content to that's why i i wonder why
that is you know i see those
same is in the youtube space and online
you see everyone give the same reads and
you're like hey i got sent that deck too
but like we twisted it in this way like
why didn't
and i think a lot of that might be the
lack of education in the space knowing
that like
for a smaller influencer we've learned
over the years because we had a team
have a team that manages
the brand partnerships and we know what
we can push back on and what what's
important to the brand
but i imagine for younger influencers
it's
you don't know if you like they're
paying you this money sometimes it's
your first year as an influencer no
it's like seasoned vets
you know like it's i think it's just
like somehow built into me i remember
the first time anybody offered me money
to show up somewhere in person like a
personal appearance thing
it was back in 2001 and january of 2001
at that
this guy says i want you to come to a
party i'll fly in i'll fly
out the next day and i'll pay 700 bucks
and i said dude 700 bucks don't just pay
me
700 bucks i will chew and swallow glass
i will light myself on fire you know
like
i want to earn it you know like i
couldn't understand how it was possibly
worth it
to this guy to pay me 700 bucks one
meanwhile jackass was the number one
show on mtv and i was a principal cast
member you're like i will pay you
and reimburse you for your plane tickets
right and uh
and then all these years later it's kind
of the same little
thing in my head where i'm like
dude like
they're paying me like good money to to
promote these
these companies and so like let me make
sure that i actually
like the company and care about like uh
their products and and let me do
like let me don't just give me the money
let me earn it you know
i love having that kind of uh a
disposition it reminds me of my first
brand deal was with um
penske the moving truck company yellow
truck
and uh they were like hey well i
remember the deal was like 500 bucks
and i think i was making two vines and
this is my two months after being on
vine
and same thing like i had never heard of
a brand deal i was like on youtube we
didn't i did a few of those but it was
mostly adsense that was paying my bills
other uh i'd be selling dvd courses for
training
for final cut pro but i got 500 bucks
for like two vines and i was same thing
i was like i mean i think i spent three
grand on that video
i rented their truck they sent me a
truck right and
they let me have it for a week to make
my video but i was like
no let me also production value let's a
thousand bucks on the lighting a
thousand bucks on the camera like let's
let's do this right and
actually get going out of pocket for
them but those are the brand deals that
are awesome though because
you still have those today it's like no
matter what the budget is you're still
going to put
so like sure you know a company came to
us years ago and was like hey we want to
do something just unexpected and
we're like well let's build a rotating
room and like let's spend tons of money
like getting the team that built the
rotating room for inception and and i'll
show you we still have a piece of it in
here when we
go into the studio but that's that's the
fun of it is like putting those budgets
back into
making something you like it's investing
in your future too yeah you know
like by doing it i i stand by that a
hundred percent
oh dude you're so ad friendly
i gotta say you know when i tell guests
that i'm jealous of them for any reason
i see like hey well don't you're jealous
hater
like and a lot of time that's just i
think my instinctual way to
you know to acknowledge and and you know
give credit
but dude like to have the audience that
you have and to
be so like ad friendly like i'll just
never be that so
like yeah it's something i i definitely
probably have taken for granted because
people tell me that and uh
but then there's these people you meet
and they try to be ad friendly on camera
but off camera you're like whoa what
you're a different different person
right but for me like that's part of my
nature i'm just a pretty
chill clean guy normally and it's funny
like
our lines are totally different on how
far we'll go but when we discuss videos
we have a whole
pile of videos that we call like the
after dark chat like if we had an after
dark channel you know like wow
where would we go with the magic if it
was like a dark comedy if we could
i'm really crude and we have a whole
list of those if you wanted to have an
only fantasy right so we've got that
list
we uh and it's funny like when we're
right in the writing room like sometimes
the jokes are hilarious but we're like
uh it just doesn't feel like would i
show my kids that someday uh what do you
have kids
i've got three kids wow how about that
how old are you i'm
i'm 30 geez i'm 31 yeah wow so
you've adopted adopted my oldest um
because my wife and i did foster care
for a couple years
and then uh we have a biological son
and then we actually have a we're doing
foster care again so we have a daughter
now
uh fantastic it's awesome so i'm a dad
of young kids you know still
not getting sleep but and they haven't
watched many of my videos they've been
in a few of them
and i've showed them when it's done and
they think it's pretty cool
but they haven't seen i i'm scared to
show my videos because i think they're
going to think it's
obviously magic like a lot of the kids i
meet do and then expect me to be cool
all the time like when i'm at home
okay so like because i don't do me like
i can't do
i can do like four coin tricks right for
them at a kid's level
they're impressed yeah you guys want to
be impressed so
that's my fear it's like when i show
them the video when they find out
there's this
mat their dad is magical like what is
their
level how is that going to raise i do
believe that we would be impressed by
whatever coin tricks you do
and my first question that i thought to
ask you
was do you get just the annoying like
every day like oh show me a trick like
can you show me a trick in person
like you got to get that more than i do
so but now i have a way to do that like
i pull out my phone and i just do
like with fans like i'll just make them
jump cut stuff like make them grab them
throw them somewhere else disappear edit
it on the spot
show that was what's great about vine
they have that feature still and
the vine camera so that's fun to do and
that's my way of like
i don't really do magic but it's weird
like kids
um i was hanging out with david we shot
a video with david blaine a couple of
months ago
i have the best david blaine story too i
can't wait to hear this and it's like
it's weird that kids will go up to him
and call his stuff magic and also call
my stuff magic i'm a little
uncomfortable
when you're out in public sure i'm like
i'm not like i know dave knows i'm not a
magician it's not like that i don't i
don't do traditional magic but yet
kids have that same amazement that they
do that feeling when they watch the
videos
so you know i i'm torn i'm like i'm not
traditionally a
magician but it's almost this new you're
a digital magician
yeah like a new term and i think that
i might get in trouble for this with
with magicians
but i think it's generous to
make the the discernment
between yeah make the distinction i
think it's generous because
you're candidly admitting that what you
do isn't magic because
you're like editing you're you know
creating an illusion
through deceptive editing right and
magic by definition is
deceptive you know like there's no we
know that
nobody has magic powers and so
essentially
uh magic is synonymous with dishonesty
right you know and so i kind of put you
in the same category but with that
that said that the level of talent that
david blaine has is off
yeah so the distinction i make is he can
do it in person
i can't right and that's what like even
though i know he's doing deception
when i watch him perform it's
unbelievable i'm
literally jaw-dropped like about to cry
you know because he's actually making it
feel like and that's at the end of the
day what matters right yeah
and and you know whatever what's your
david blaine story
okay dude i i met him in new york
and uh we were in a restaurant or a bar
or something like that
and uh and and i was
just gung-ho to show him uh
one of my bar tricks i've always been
like like a magic trick yeah and i have
a video on youtube called my 10
best bar tricks and i just show them all
and give away the secrets and everything
and it's like one of my top performing
videos on youtube
and i've loaded them all into one video
that's the demographic of that video can
you see
who's watching that i don't know but
it's pretty popular
so i hit him with my bread winner which
was uh
i said dude i'm gonna here's this this
cup you know with with
a drink in it i'm gonna place this drink
i'm gonna balance it on my
on my head as soon as i let go of the
cup i'm gonna put my arms down by my
side and i will not raise my arms
at all and i'm gonna drink this drink
without spilling a drop
and he says yeah you're going to lay
down you're going to
bring up your knees you're going to pick
it up with your knees off your forehead
and you're going to place it on the
ground pick it up and i was like oh
[Laughter]
and then i was like i said i said oh
okay forget that one
i just i so i say uh i just said i got
this dime
and i'm gonna put it on the table and
i'm gonna take this glass pint glass and
i'm gonna balance it on
the the corner on the edge of the you
know the corner of the base of this
glass i'm gonna balance this pint glass
on an
angle on the top face of the dime i'm
gonna let go and it's gonna balance
perfectly
he says yeah you're gonna do it in the
like uh
you know and then the back of his neck i
prefer doing it on the bridge of the
nose on the nickel
yeah and then my third try was uh i said
i've said
take an ashtray i put it on the table
and i think this was back when you could
still smoke too
this was all in in the scent you were
like sitting yeah
my third my third time adam i'm in the
same setting as
i took an ashtray but i said okay here's
this ashtray it's on the table
now here's this dime i put it on the
table
like uh you know a couple inches away
from the ashtray now i'm going to put my
hands behind my back
i'm not going to touch anything and i'm
going to without touching
anything i'm going to put that dime into
the ashtray
and that he didn't know it and he's like
you could see the interesting thing are
you gonna interrupt me
his eyes lit up a little bit and you
know and like he didn't know where i was
going with it
and i put my hands behind my back i took
a deep breath and i went
and i blew the dime and so i didn't
touch anything
yeah and and dude he saw that dime and
thank god i got out of the first try
because it's not the kind of trick you
get every
you know yeah but he saw the dime land
in the ashtray and he's
just he said oh my god do you mind if i
tell people this
people come up to me all day
every day will i do a trick and
this is the perfect trick
for me to share with them can i do that
to yeah that's cool
is the best that's so fun yeah yeah i
always wondered how he like
got the bar the did you ever see him go
to jail and then he
pulled open the bars and yeah i i wish i
knew how to do that yeah i mean
it's insane how long does it take you to
feel like to
finish a video start to finish start to
finish we try it takes us
average a month um wow and that's kind
of with like one producer and
one editor going at it the whole time
from riding to the end there's tricks
that
have taken us six months to break a year
one video
a couple years of and it usually starts
with like this honestly the story isn't
right
like it starts in the writing room if we
don't walk away from the table loving
the idea
we kind of know those ones are gonna die
they're gonna have some sort of problem
um later on until we get that spark back
and and connect those dots of what that
story is
so wow i mean the rotating room one um
for example was a massive
one that we we just green lit we're like
we're gonna figure out the story later
and then we ended up doing some stuff
with uh
kind of gravity and walking on the walls
obviously
but it's sometimes you know the story
and you green light it sometimes you
just know the trick and you know the
build like
hey people are gonna just freak out when
they see him the mirror is the reveal
harry potter like let's just go out to
the parking lot
and start working on it so you have it's
a whole range of them but
for us the creative process is like you
have to just be open to all the way
through like ready to rewrite
on set ready to change and i think in
we kind of draw a lot from the animation
process some of our team has been
uh worked at pixar before come from
other animation studios
and so we like to not only storyboard
the stuff but
make what we call mock-ups of it so
we're seeing it like four or five times
shot on like someone's phone um really
really bad renderings of the tricks
but we've seen it you know four or five
times before we really shoot it
so that it's at least got in the
elements that we really love about it
um how much of a role does green screen
play
in your work green screen plays small
role probably under five percent
and all this stuff it really for me it's
gotta be practical it absolutely has to
be like when i watch jurassic park as a
kid which is one of the movies that
inspired me to get into it
it was the behind the scenes of it that
really drew me in because i was like
sure wait they built the dinosaur head
for real like a what 20 foot by 30 foot
just the head like that amazed me and
the fact that like
i i always i always think you could tell
like maybe not anymore
but you know when you're watching a
marvel movie and you're like oh well
they're just like
it's a green screen and they've got some
really great costumes and um
right you know what you almost can see
that the depth is fake and just
elements something sticks out and you
can't quite put your finger on it for me
the like the the marvel of phenomena is
less about whether it looks real or fake
and more about just like
i kind of lost interest in all that
stuff a long time ago because i feel
that i can
only suspend so much disbelief sure
once it gets so over the top and so far
fetched like i just kind of tune out
yeah i think there's a group there's
like several groups of people i fall in
that category
but i know there's a group of people
because half of them are at the studio
where
they do buy into so much more than i do
and i'm like i don't want to ruin it for
them like
you know whatever if they love it that's
awesome i'll go to the theater with them
and enjoy it
um and enjoy the popcorn but for me it's
like
i also love it being practical on set
because
we find most our success in like the one
like the harry potter video for example
like
it was on set that we made the final
tweaks of like whatever the story beat
was or what hit
what was what was funny at the end or
even the trick how like we do the camera
reveal like it all is very specific
to me if it's not practical and you're
in a green screen room you have nothing
to touch you have nothing to move you
have nothing to really interact with
to give you like and then also the
cameraman like for me or the camera
gal is like it's a choreographed dance
between us
and that we found affects the way the
trick is revealed the amount of awe
someone has like if you
do the opposite camera move it might be
a totally different reveal and it's like
not that cool so all those elements go
into it but
having it in a practical set makes the
difference that dance come alive yeah
how do you find the right cameraman for
that i'm sure you had to go through a
bunch
yeah we go through a bunch of them um
the big thing is like we call it you
can't have shaky hands that's the only
like it's really difficult
if you can see the camera shaking but i
got to get props to my camera team it's
actually
probably mostly gals now that do the
camera work but it's we
i mean we do the not only the takes like
70 times average
but we do the practice like another 30
times so you're doing it like a hundred
times
sounds like me trying to trying to land
a skateboard trick
very similar yeah over and over yeah and
uh so of course your hands are shaking
by the end of it
wow that's fascinating um i asked about
the green screen because
um i got it in my head that i wanted to
make a green screen video a while back
and i finally got around to it what is a
green screen video is that you floating
i wanted to make a video with green
screen illusions okay
and uh i when and this the first time
that that uh
that you came up with my podcast booker
i was like oh we're gonna reach out to
zach king and i was like oh my god
i have an idea to pitch green screen
illusions right green and and i was
working on it at the same time
and uh it was right when i was wrapping
up that video i feel like and and i
asked them to send it to you
and when is it done i've never seen it
yeah it is done
one of the ideas that i had it was up in
my living room
and i said hurry i'm gonna turn on this
tv and my edit bay downstairs
appeared on the thing okay i said now
i'm going to dive into my edit page so i
the illusion was i bounced off a
trampoline like
very much into the tv and came out of
the tv oh i have to see this
i have to see this yeah i was really
excited about it you just grabbed a
plate of you diving into the editing
and we said it we set up a green screen
and uh measured the distance from the
trampoline to the tv
you know we cut the exact size tv
out of the the green screen and uh
you know just all we do we set up with
tape measures like uh
so yeah i mean i imagine i haven't seen
it but i imagine
it actually looks good because you did
the measurements that's what you did
yeah and you did the framing
and by the virtue of taking a
measurement to the middle of the lens
from
each bottom corner of the tv it's
impossible to not have it in the same
yeah we get we get probably a couple
thousand videos sent to us each month of
fans that try you know and that's a
popular one they do
and the thing they always mess up is
like they clearly didn't measure the
angle of the uh
jumping actually really matters like how
you jump from relation to the camera but
for us
it's actually easier because that is a
lot of work what you just described
right and for our team like we also only
want to do that once so we don't do that
we'll actually build
it is slightly more work but it's also
cooler because again it's practical we
would build that set like your edit bay
we cut a hole in the real tv
behind and the hard part is it sounds
like that set would have to be pretty
far away like another 10 feet from the
tv hole but that's how we pull that off
i'm just cutting a hole in the wall and
that's why we ended up at the studio
because
our original landlords were like hey you
gotta stop cutting like we were hitting
plane plumbing and
electrical and they're like hey you guys
gotta get that's crazy build sets
um my it was that i would yeah i'll be
dying after after we wrap up i'll show
you the uh
the screen video i made it didn't
perform very well and it was like all
right you know
i what do you want they don't say i
looked at the thumbnails like green
screen illusions like isn't green screen
already we're not but
like it was it was tanking terribly and
so i was like
i changed the title to stevo exposed
fake stunts
and then when did it go up marginally
yeah marginally and um so uh
okay i wanted when uh we were having the
discussion about
getting together with you i said i sent
a treatment
to try to shoot a video with you um
and and and it was it's less i think
green screen motivated but maybe a
little bit
and uh camera's gonna spill it out on
the podcast what the idea is
but it's essentially like i want to just
tell an over the top
like the craziest story ever told and
like with the with the
the the illusions and the trickery just
make make it like i'm narrating the
story that you're watching happen yeah
the story would go something like this
man i
just can't believe the craziest thing
happened i was like walking through this
this alley and out of nowhere a
humongous sledgehammer just comes
swinging through on a rope
clocks me right in the head and and
there i am laying there and i think
i i i think i'm dead and
sure enough can we see your head explode
or something
that beautiful and sure enough like i
was dead
and then it got even crazier because my
my soul
like you know uh like
left my body and so you've got this like
sort of opaque
like uh green effect opaque like you
know
fluorine you know like floating up out
of the body and i was
i was in between bodies for a while but
it was crazy because i was able to
influence like the physical
world around me you know i was doing
like crazy tricks and freaking people
out
you know but then all of a sudden who
would you believe it i saw zach king
and i literally possessed the guy and it
was like some crazy exorcist thing man
because like now i had it you know
whatever and then what what happens
i mean i don't know open-ended at that
point at that point i was seeking to
collaborate with you
i think it'd be funny to take that and
you would possess multiple celebrities
yeah
like that that would be great right
uh-huh like not just one
and um my buddy has a working
relationship
with the oscar winning i believe the
academy award-winning
uh makeup artist makeup effects guy for
uh a shape of water okay like there's
some crazy
like monster creature and this guy like
this is like some ozzy osbourne bark the
moon thing where they like put each you
know
like high level special effects and
character
and they say that not only can this guy
uh make
like a make me into any creature but he
could
actually make me into recognizable
celebrities where i can like literally
walk around
in person and be that wow so is that how
you pull it off
i mean i don't know i i don't know i
mean and in our case we could just go
like to act like you you know yeah like
the lindsay lohan movie kind of a deal
and we can overdub each other's way like
when we actually adopt each other's
voices
but uh yeah i mean it'd be super fun
yeah and it would die i would imagine
that that video would be an undertaking
so what i
from taking me six months to do it in my
world maybe a weak
what's interesting like the only place
we start to think about
engagement and making a video uh when
we're developing it is like
the length there is like something to
the algorithm for the length and if on
youtube you're hitting that six
to ten minutes that's a great length to
be at but
that sounds like almost like a two
minute sketch
right i don't know how long that that
would be but i think that uh
what i did with the green screen video
was to like
reveal the stunt and then kind of get
into the
like the the making of it you know that
and i think i i was pretty effective in
in making dude like i
i give a about my videos you know
and sometimes like with the green screen
video
like people don't want to see like
anything fake for me so i understand but
god i loved i loved working on that yeah
that's awesome
yeah how long are your youtube videos in
general i mean dude i just went through
this
phase where uh i i decided to swing
after me and casey neistat
i decided now i'm gonna get into
vlogging okay so you actually did i did
your meeting i did
okay and um and it was a really fun
thing to do oh i'm still
i mean i'd do one a week okay one so one
a week very doable and
it was it was a meaningful step for me
because what i had been doing and being
rather successful at on youtube was
uh mining through and repurposing
footage
like accumulated over the last like
literally decades you know and i would
make it into like top 10 videos
and ultimately it made me feel like the
guy who the grown man who won't shut up
about what
what he was able to bench press in high
school sure you know like
living in the past and regaling all of
this old stuff
and like you know it was it got a little
bit embarrassing that i was
you know living in the past like that
and so to switch to vlogging
represented like just a uh
you know a refresh on what i'm doing and
it was exciting
but i was very sensitive to the idea
that a lot of vloggers put out like 20
minute long videos where nothing happens
right
and the guy who was the exception to
that rule
like really like impressively was david
dobrik and he had this weird thing
about making his videos four minutes and
20 seconds where like
more happened at that 420 like
jam-packed
so jam-packed where it's like oh my god
like you were hanging out with david
dobrik and borat and gave each of them
like 15 seconds of screen time
you know so i just felt that that four
minutes and 20 seconds was
really like embodied the idea of like
not wasting the viewers time yep
and i just copied it so you're yeah
that's great so you're
weak i mean imagine has a lot of
interesting stuff is that what you're
essentially doing is
just fast fast but i try to make it but
now like i got
embarrassed of like copying david
dobert's four minute in 20 long so i'm
like now i'm
making a point of just letting it be
what i think it should be
and generally and sometimes it's coming
up less than four minutes and 20 seconds
sometimes a little bit more but
but i am so careful about not wasting
my audience's time like the best comment
i could ever see on a youtube video is
man
longer videos please yeah that's all i
want and he
he sits there shaking his head he's like
dude your cutting room floor
is a gold mine like if i can
just let it play he's
begging me let it play i'm like begging
him i mean dude
the amount of minutes because you have
so much that's like
epic that you cut out and it's such a
it's almost like a disservice to the
person that's watching it because
we work really hard on a lot of cool
you know and then it's like
i'm like what happened to that part he's
like god dude we just cut it i'm like
you cut you know you know it's just
crazy
so and and for a while there scott was
uh
taking everything i cut putting it on
his youtube channel which really is a
good channel yeah yeah
dude it's some of the most epic footage
of my life
it should be yeah but but but it's crazy
i mean
some of the stuff that like some of the
clips that are like you know 10 seconds
long
right they could play out 45 seconds and
it'd be like oh my god people want to
see that
yeah it's like no it has to be perfect
it has to be good
you know it makes the cut i mean i i do
agree i
i wish i could see the scraps but like i
do agree with you because
attention has been getting shorter i
mean you could argue from the day you
guys went on mtv and i'm like sure
there was feature film documentarians i
know they mentioned you had a podcast
and they were like the competition that
weekend was one of your new shows
and they're worried about someone
watching their eight episodes of this
documentary that's you know
right three hours long in episode and so
attention has been destroyed for a long
time but you know it's easy
like it's gone like kind of like global
warming makes it hotter
and colder at the same time you just it
just goes to completely polar extremes
and at the same time that the attention
span
uh has gotten so painfully short
it's also gotten so painfully long like
we see what's happened with the
binging of like full tv series like with
podcasts like people will put up and
listen to
like you know i know podcasters who put
up like two and three hour episodes and
people are just begging for them to be
longer like
it was tough for me to get it i have a
format for you to check out then um
might give you more inspiration it's i
think his name is ross creations
and he's a guy down in florida does
crazy pranks but
they're also you get to see so basically
what i'm getting at is
i think his videos are six to 10 minutes
long but he highlights and what is
what i appreciate about is his his
headline which is the click bait not
clickbaity but that's sure the attention
grabbing is almost
salacious yeah it doesn't start with it
but he does in the beginning give a
little text
open yep no like basically like where
you can find it it's at 340 and it's in
yellow and that's the only thing in
yellow
and i usually skip straight there but if
i really want to hang out with him
i'll watch the whole thing around it and
it's a genius way to do it because
he probably trends every single video
for what it's listed as
but yet it's padded within an eight to
ten minute thing which is great for
youtube
so look into that format i'd be really
interested to see what it does to
analytics when because you can actually
embed
and share a youtube video where when you
click on it
it goes to a starting point you see it
on tmz all the time yeah
and i wonder what that like what the
implications are on
analytics for retention for viewership
like when
when that's utilized yeah imagine you
just see the hotspot there
uh it probably changes your whole view
duration your average view
right um i mean it's interesting man the
world has certainly changed a great deal
man
yeah like in our lifetimes and that and
that's where like i think it'll continue
to change and evolve there'll be a
million platforms that come out
and at the end of the day that's why i
think we come back to like is the story
interesting you have a gut for when to
cut
or how long to hold like that's what's
important you're you're holding them as
long as
you know you obviously go into
respecting your audience like i'm not
i'm not wanting to make them watch
another minute and a half of this
because it's
i don't think it's good like cut her out
and that's great um
and for us it just starts with what is
that story and why are we holding their
attention in the first place
right why are we asking for it uh-huh
man
like your sensibility for entertainment
uh
is is impressive and i i couldn't help
but catch that you started out
as a guy who taught final cut yeah i
taught final cut pro for
many many years and it's fun i still
meet a lot of fans who either got into
filmmaking because of it or
um now like i'm meeting fans it kind of
comes full circle they have businesses
that are in
videography or film industry for it
going all the way back to when you were
teaching yeah they were watching the
youtube channel
yeah so youtube tutorials on how to use
yeah
it was early days of youtube already you
got to make money from it you were just
posting and
at the time it was like i didn't think
youtube was the front runner it was
going to be vimeo
or is going to be dailymotion or yahoo
video and so i was posting my tutorials
on all those things
uh was this before or after final cut
seven was way before
okay uh this it had to be i was showing
final cut 6 i think was the first okay
but i started in final cut 3 and then
and then it turned to
four or five and then i think they were
in studio bundles and you'd get the
whole like motion you'd get dvd studio
pro
um how long did you hang on to final cut
seven
i mean when it was ten i it was still
ten for like three years when i was
editing final cut pro 7.
in fact i still have they still have the
preference options
to edit using the key commands from
final cut pro 7 in in premiere
oh okay so that's what i edit on like i
don't know the the premiere
shortcuts i go default um yeah you're on
default you said
yeah yeah but i'm on the final cut pro 7
because i edited it on so long
um but yeah i was teaching final cut pro
because i didn't get into film school my
first year
so i kind of had this one year of like
not a lot to do
and i was like already getting ahead of
my film i had buddies that were in the
film program so i was like okay what's
your what are you doing this weekend for
the film
101 course like i was making those
shorts ahead of time
and then along the way because i love
final cut and i was like a software nerd
i would film my screen at night do these
tutorials post them on youtube
vimeo everywhere else and eventually
youtube became the front runner
you still couldn't make money from it
but i was selling dvd courses and that's
how i was paying through film school
like i was like shipping them and
labeling them out of my dorm room
and they were like 10 hour courses so i
gave like i mean i'm proud of what i did
because i gave hundreds and hundreds of
hours of training for free online
but it was always like it was that was
the one place i pushed push merch and it
worked really well
which is like hey if you want the 10
hour version of like 20 other effects
that i teach
it's down below and like people were
stoked on it so i did that for many
years that's
when i graduated film school i was still
doing that business and that's what
actually funded the first
uh studio operations for me um like i
thought that would be my business for a
while
and then eventually youtube adsense took
off a little more
vine took off i remember youtube adsense
coming out and uh
2007 yeah but you had to apply and so i
had applied and never got in for there
was a couple year window
i think i started adsense in 2010 or 11.
okay it was late
like they had that partner program but
it was exclusive it was like if you knew
someone at youtube you could maybe
apply and get in right you got to be one
of the top accounts
bro man you strike me as a guy who loves
his work so much that everything that
you've made
just goes right back into your work and
that's why you've been able to grow
as exponentially as you have it's fun i
mean that's the filmmaker in me is is
wanting to like
you know it was always as a kid like
production value like
a train's coming like roll the camera
you know like go near the train and and
pretend we paid for it and so now that
the fact that you could pay well i
haven't done that one that'd be cool
kind of
i have a trained concept so maybe i
should hire a train how much would that
cost
oh that was what my next question after
uh was
how big of a role does green screen play
how big of a roll
does uh a dolly track a computerized
programmable
dollar track that can repeat motion
control yeah
well because the technology it's really
expensive to rent
we have rented uh like the bottom dolly
one um and there's these companies you
know the company that did um
do you know do you know the behind the
scenes of how gravity was made i didn't
even watch gravity the movie
yeah the movie it was sandra bullock
yeah was that sandra and george clooney
yeah
so they put them inside kind of a
mechanical
rig called i think one of them was
bought and the other one was dolly and
so one was for the camera
and one was to their body rig and that's
how they did the motions to time and do
it over and over
and over zero gravity kind of thing yeah
and so that same technology was put into
motion controls and you can rent their
system it's just really expensive
like every day is like 10 or 15 000
which we're not going to pay
but they're they're consumer level ones
yeah if you like
hit record on the camera like it changes
the whole thing like it's got to be
perfect
so we don't do a lot of remote control
well so we don't do a yeah you have to
do a remote control
um there's a few that hook up to like a
ps5 or xbox controller
you can control but they're still so
like i'm excited for that
i like it doesn't even have this motion
yet like it needs to have
it's just usually like on a dolly and
you can you can tell so we'll do
some of that once in a while when it's
like oh it'd be sweet to have camera
motion in this way but for us it's
usually
handheld because what we're also going
for the aesthetic is like
an iphone or we're going for like a
friend filming it vertically for you
right
that's part of the aesthetic to buy into
the magic is like if it was
a highly produced piece and you could
just tell you're kind of like well i'm
watching
highly produced pieces i understood but
that's why the
the programmable motion dolly is so
important
because with with that motion comes
the if you're on if you're on a tripod
and you're
like doing layers then okay that's lame
i'm saying that's where we skip and it
just takes way more visual effects time
but we'll just have the
per the camera person walk around like
right it still
feels we actually just did a motion
control piece a few weeks ago
even if you're like programming what
you're trying to do like program it to
be like shitty
yeah someone walking and like how you
actually get the camera
it's so smooth like the right the
the interpolation kind of gets messed up
and it never
feels right what about uh that crazy
mechanical arm
that they use for the phantom camera
where it's gosh
yes i've never used the the bolt i think
it's super fast it's like yeah
you do a lot of food product shots slow
motion circling the food
i haven't used them but not even not not
slow motion circling the food but like
where it's uh like some crazy action
movie like
you know you've got like oh that's the
three things
all the 360 ones well yeah so that in
like
15 000 frames per second or whatever
obnoxious slo-mo
yes uh and like the camera's moving
like so fast that you when you slow it
down it's
super slow you've got this great fluid
motion
yeah like how they shot i think they did
a little crouching tiger hidden dragon
300 like that i love all that stuff man
yeah i feel like we would have
so much fun together on a collab that
would be sweet yeah
super slow motion and you're sick one
thing i'm working on
like uh i made a big deal out of is
because i have a
fiance now and i really wanted to
uh sort of redecorate our whole house
such that it would
feel like ours rather than her being a
guest in my bachelor pad
and uh we've been working on that term
slowly over time
and it's made me want so badly to do a
house tour video yeah
but like who hasn't done a house
tour video and like you know and
so i i just want that to be filled with
tricks like where
you know a magical makeover house
house tour so like you would show is it
currently a bachelor pad
i mean this has been going on is it
already it's been going on over time
it's been gradually morphing but like to
make it fun
what i want to do is like you know here
i am okay it's time for me to give a
house tour i open up the door and
it's me you know i was trying to give
myself a house tour
and i want it packed with celebrities
and begging gordon ramsay to be like
cooking up dinner in the kitchen you
know like i have a game room and i'm
dying to go play ping pong with justin
bieber yeah
and i've saved the outfit you know so i
can like
perfect i just make it all i wanted full
of illusions and
celebrities and just like make
it so fun and that's one
that i will work on for months and
months that's cool
yeah yeah i can't imagine if you did a
movie how long that would take you to
make
do you want to do movies um i used to
want to do movies i still have the itch
i'm we're doing a lot of fun longer form
stuff on youtube and it's
to the point where we can almost
self-fund it and
i think the monetization is a couple
years out where like
it doesn't make sense to necessarily
partner with a streaming service unless
they're bringing
a ton of views um the other really
interesting partnership is also youtube
originals where
they're you know investing back into
your channel and it's going back to the
audience because i've always
we've done done the whole hollywood
picture out for
different streaming shows and you sit in
development forever
oh my god tell me about it and then you
spend yeah you know and then you spend
time
forget about even development you see
you get jammed up over
the contract to even start really
developing yeah exactly and
you're stuck in that and then you're
spending all that time and you realize
at the end of the day it's going to go
on some other platform some other
networks
your audience i mean maybe you could
tell your audience about it but like
if my audience is on youtube or online
like i want to put that stuff back there
where it's going to feed and grow that
and continue that right i mean dude i'm
in this exact same situation right now
raj i'm saying way too much uh i became
a tattoo artist and i really put up
it just started as a youtube video like
what if i tried my
ass off to like give people really good
tattoos because i had already had like
fans show up like oh dude put your name
and get on like
so i've done it before it's like man
when and then this
kid says will you tattoo me and while i
was tattooing him i thought what if i
really put an effort into it yeah so i
tried my ass off i got my bro
to really teach me and i was shocked by
like what i was able to accomplish
and then all of a sudden i was like dude
let me make a project out of
this
you know and uh and and i made a couple
of videos
they were fun they liked it it was great
because the tattoos i choose to give
people are
you know the combination of like guys
people want me to tattoo them so badly
they don't care if it's up
right and they're willing to get
whatever
whatever you want to put on right so
that whole dynamics really funny
and uh and it's turned into a television
series
conversation which has been jammed up in
the contract phase
and now you're thinking like i wish why
can't i do this
it's been jammed up over the contract
for and we're just not like on the same
page and i'm just like i've been
thinking to myself
it's not worth it dude like it
like i would
do way better to keep it in my own
ecosystem like you're talking about
right and the long tail of it i imagine
too
the content living even way past your
lifetime like the value is gonna be in
the library for the estate
for the great grandchildren right but
yeah there's value in the library too
over time and that's
dude i had the same thing happen with my
uh comedy special i put out this
you know i've been doing stand-up for
like well over a decade now
and uh when it came to my second comedy
special
uh my head exploded when i came up with
the idea to
not just show me performing the stand-up
but to
interstitially edit in the footage of
the stories that i'm telling in my stand
up
so i made this like completely original
multimedia comedy special
and uh reunited on the whole cast of
jackass it was just my masterpiece and
yeah
that was like i poured a good 300 000
into producing it yeah wow and then and
then after producing it myself i brought
it out just like oh man they're gonna
freak over this
and everybody rejected it because they
were like uh
just not bullish on stevo stand up
comedy
despite the fact that it was so original
and like such the best thing i've ever
made
yeah so i just doubled down i worked on
got to work on the next project
and uh you know came up with a paywall
system on my own website
and so now it's been hugely successful
for me i still own it and i've proven
the value of what i'm doing
yeah i met so how does that work the
streaming service would they own or
network oh yeah all those story like
would you not be able to tell the story
oh i don't know about like gags
i don't know about that i i just did a
new book deal
too and uh and now you're like shoot i i
know that on my book deal
that uh i retained like you know movie
rights if i want to sell it like i'm not
so i i would have but yeah and like like
like
you know if i was gonna go try and
reshoot the same
act right like david chappelle can't go
re-perform and re-shoot the same acting
so yeah they would they would own the
material yeah
yeah that it's crazy to the whole
landscape and i know i
can already feel like all the comments
you shut the up steven you've been
talking the whole time
but i feel like uh most of what's been
said around
across the boards has been very
interesting man yeah
yeah it's fun it's like i think that
being in the new frontier is
more fun than trying to reverse engineer
what's happening here in
in hollywood right um it's crazy man
like
you know i i look at uh like the
howard stern i'm not sure how familiar
with him but he's like you know
undeniably always has been the king of
all media yep you know he's just like
and he's just like a representation of
old school entertainment industry where
like what what he
is impressed by is movie stars like you
know like
classic like you know old school model
and you know
but then what like joe rogan being of
the new school has crept up with like
the whole digital landscape and really
you know you've got
howard stern and joe rogan and and uh
i don't know if joe rogan's overtaken
howard stern
but i certainly wouldn't be surprised
and uh i consider myself uh of the joe
rogan ilk
yeah you know where knoxville my body is
distinctly more in the howard stern
headspace yeah
and i think both can exist in the world
together coexist
there's some version of it that hasn't i
don't know but
uh i'd much rather be in
what i think is more the innovative and
the newer frontier
yeah so what uh like what can we
help you promote uh tick-tock are you
looking for followers
looking for followers we can get fifty
thousand
um i don't have anything to promote i
mean if you're a kid i have a book
series that's really fun
uh if you're in like a middle it's a
middle grade reader okay and that's
really cool it's like a three-part
series
we i would me and this is like actually
answering that question about kids who
would come up and be like
do a magic trick for me you know a lot
of kids would come up and i'd be like
hey
dude i'm so sorry it's editing like
here's how it worked and they walk away
like bummed out
and i was like okay well i would love to
give them something that was like you
know
especially like the four through
eight-year-olds who almost still believe
it's real
i wanted to give them something so i was
like okay let's write a book series
it'll have the story of like
zach in a magical family but he doesn't
have magic and
in the series he goes gets sent to
middle school which is also just a fun
time to play in
a lot of kids lives and talk about that
but what if you did find out you had
magic and like what would you you know
in my kind of magic um so that's what
the book series was and that's my like
my fun thing to give to kids now and i
carry around them in my car with my
kids in public it's like no i can't do
magic but here's here's a
like book to keep it alive for another
year for you that's cool okay
and does that book uh bestow upon the
the reader the ability to do magic
themselves is it instructional well
actually no but it kind of does there's
a bunch of companion apps that are free
that go along with it so on your phone
it brings all the art to life in like an
augmented way
cool so wow yeah we found a lot of kids
actually with uh
autism and parents will share the series
because it gets their kids into reading
for the first time wow so that's a cool
benefit like a side
thing that's happened yeah and how do
people find that book it's not on amazon
or amazon yeah on the most popular book
book site in the world you know
yeah what's uh
and what's the title of it um zach king
my magical life is the first one
zac king my magical life and that will
lead people and that'll lead them down
the rapid trail okay good it's great
it's great so so we got the book
we got the tick tock we got the youtube
yeah how often do you upload on youtube
youtube is once a week on average that's
that's that's the hard i don't know your
your cadence
but that is a hard cadence to do at
least for my stuff because it takes so
much time
and like again i'm not i'm like you i'm
not gonna just sit and vlog for six
minutes because it hits the window like
it's got to be
interesting absolutely so if we go a
week or two without posting it's also
like we're not killing ourselves
um but that generally once a week is our
our target
and then uh two shorter pieces every
week it's it's it's
a lot it's a lot even like for me and
and i i feel like
i'm pretty psycho over my editing yeah
over my standards and
and uh but still not quite you yes i can
only imagine but
we do we upload every week to four
different youtube channels i'm just i'm
jealous of tv shows and the cadence they
have of this idea of a season break
yeah like the fact i mean i think we've
been going for
at least on the current stuff that
people would watch like we've been doing
this for seven eight years
at that cadence of trying to do once a
week trying to do
two pieces a week and you i mean we take
breaks obviously and
we'll tr but it's hard for us to like
stockpile the stuff yeah i think in
coyotes episode he was like yeah i have
14 episodes and i'm listen i'm like
are you kidding i'm barely finishing the
next one that's coming out next week
it's called paycheck to paycheck i've
got like this video you know a massive
team helping me like we can't break that
cycle
right but um i think that's it's
it's part of the fun is like just
continuing to and it allows you to be
fresh though with
at least you can play something that's
trending that's something sure that is
nice about
constantly being on but by the way thank
you for listening to the coyote peterson
oh that was a fun one i was when you
were like
okay let's break down the business model
yeah don't get awkward coyote let's go
top three right yeah what's your top
three uh i think i shared
minus merch that won't be in the top
three but um bran
to branded integration branded
integrations uh we do a lot of
production work
so oh wow you shoot a lot of stuff that
i'm not in that
you want to you might know if you watch
a commercial and you're like oh that's
a similar type of magic like we probably
maybe okay
but you won't see me in it have you done
a super bowl commercial
i was in a super bowl commercial last
year god damn
it for three seconds it's mainstream
folks
it was with uh it was with sabra and
what i wanted to do it was last minute
like
they had 25 different celebrities and
influencers in there and they said
you know you get zach you get a second
like let us know what you want to do and
i was like well
if i had if you give me like eight
seconds i could what if we froze this
like that's my dream is to freeze the
super bowl feed and let
people really think it's frozen and then
do some of our classic kind of like
unplaying the the icons or restarting
your tv for you
gags but they're like okay we can get
you three seconds
well you're like
yeah someone told me on their team
they're like dude this is like worth
half a million dollars so
yeah just you should take the three and
be happy and we're and right and that's
a 30-second spot that is like what 30
is it really 30 million bucks so yeah
well it's like
eight nine i think yeah you're right
it's like somewhere between you have to
spend another 12.
wait no i think it's 5 million for 30
seconds yeah but then you have to spend
another like 10 to 15 million
over the course of the month with with
the network right
um so yeah it's it's probably 23 million
as a buy-in
right and so it's that was one of the
projects i was like you know
three seconds what can i put into this
like so we tried to freeze it for a
second
uh two seconds but still the gag didn't
fully pay off because he had oh dude
don't we gotta edit that out for you
dude
we can't we gotta edit that out for we
can't say that you came up
short for the story it
it's not what it could have been okay
their override was fine i mean they
still had 25. you know what
leave it in because your integrity
speaks volumes it's
not dissing their ad just what we could
have done the potential
anything else we can uh direct some
traffic to no that's it dude the to the
to the honey hives
uh they can get honey i'm just kidding
i got into beekeeping a couple years ago
i try to give this to everybody that
that crystallization is okay
and the dude this is a hundred percent
superfood yeah
yeah you said the honey hive do you have
one of those boxes where they go on you
just
tap it no those apparently you know i
don't want to
i can't imagine them working but like i
can imagine them working i can't imagine
them being great for the bees i don't
have those they're just a standard i
don't know what called traditional
beekeeper and you dress up in the whole
garb and then
i have to i'm like definitely allergic
so oh i'm trying to think of a name
for the honey i'm never gonna sell it
but i want to give it away wait to see
our new jackass movie jackass forever
oh no the bee bit in there is that the
limo bit no no that was on jackass
number two we got a new jackass movie
coming out
okay so what is it i can't tell you what
it is
did you have honeybees or did you have
africanized businesses ah
they were like normally with bees i've
been very good about just like stay calm
and i'll be all right yeah
in this case i didn't do and they
started stinging me right that
makes me think that they were
africanized because
honeybees like same way like you can i
used to handle them before i found out i
was allergic
and they're fine they're not going to
sing you but africanized bees which are
the ones like
i post on craigslist to get all my my
hives for free
so but usually those ones are the wild
africanized bees that
are super aggressive like they'll
they'll sting through your suit you know
really so like i wonder if that's what
they threw on the show i mean dude
it's for i didn't even get my intro out
and i was getting tagged
yeah yeah well hey man dude thank you so
much dude
i'll take it to the studio yeah let's do
it
did i tell you that was magical or what
yeah dude ah what can i say
dude the bucket list tour really was
unbelievably insane
i did the uh the
big high dive belly flop into
the pure piss that i was talking about
for so long right before i got it ready
man that
worked great and then there's the other
nude bit with the four
inch needle going in my spine dude i had
no idea how that would be received and
it
like they're going crazy for it dude i
love the bucket list tour
and you know
the meet and greets are a lot but i've
been doing them so
i'll see you on the road yeah dudes
thanks so much